In this lesson, we're going to look at living in groups and the social
influence of others. And we're going to do so by breaking the lesson into three
sections. In the first section, we're going to look at forces that change our
behavior and this includes social facilitation and social loafing as well as
conformity and obedience. In the second part of the lesson we're going to look
at social forces that change our perception and attitudes towards others. And
this includes social perception theory and attribution theory as well as
inclusion and exclusion. Prejudice and discrimination, as well as our attitudes
and our behaviors. And then finally in the third section we're going to look at
how we act towards others. And this includes aggressiveness and pro-social
behavior, as well as who we like, attraction, and what love is. But let's get
started with social forces. I remember back in junior high school when one of
my friends was having a party. Everybody was talking about the invitations that
they got, what they were going to wear to the party, how exciting it was going
to be. And given that I had been invited to parties in this group of friends in
the past, I had assumed that I would be invited to this one as well. However,
it turns out that I realized quite quickly I was not invited to this party. And
I remember feeling a pit in my stomach, I was angry, I was sad, I was envious.
And most of all I felt pain. I had just experienced my first harsh encounter
with social rejection.